it was another terrible 7 days for the
NFL with yet more news regarding serious
domestic abuse
everyone had significant questions for
NFL Commissioner Roger Goodell regarding
how the NFL handles domestic abuse and
what specific plans he has to improve
things in the future so on Friday he
spent an entire 45 minutes answering
none of them these incidents demonstrate
that we can use the NFL to help create
change we are taking a number of steps
we will re-examine enhance and improve
all of our current programs and then
will do more there will be changes to
our personal conduct policy I know this
because we will make it happen
we've acknowledged that we need to
change what we're doing now we have to
get to what are those changes going to
be and in so saying I've effectively
made sounds which when put together
constitute words which can then be
turned into sentences that make noise to
travel into your ears and that's 45
minutes I've done it Goodell out
the low points of the press conference
might have been when Goodell had this
exchange with a reporter from TMZ I
would have loved to have seen that tape
should we do more to get that
information in the future that's a
question I'm Harmony's experts to do we
found out by one phone call you guys
have a whole legal department okay you
know you know that things are not going
well when you lose the moral high ground
to a TMZ Roberta
a man whose employer ran a story this
week titled nicki manaj bamboo balls her
ass critics and the thing is Goodell
wasn't just getting criticized in the
room if you were watching on ESPN you
could see NFL players live tweets the
proceedings including Darius Butler who
wrote this press conference is pointless
and you know what Darius was right in
fact Darius is right about everything
that he watches on television just a few
days later I was watching NBC's the
mysteries of Laura when a tweet of his
popped up saying yes the reviews have
been bad but it's good to see Debra
Messing back on TV where she belongs
you're right again Darius you've really
got your finger on the pulse of America
what's ruling but truly the single
greatest reaction to the entire Goodell
press conference debacle came from wide
receiver Sidney Rice who wrote simply
Buddhist man ghost emoted and I really
think that says it all Bravo Sidney
the moji engine